murder hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to yandere
simulator now the last time that I
played this and on the day that I
released the video there was actually an
update release for the game and now
there's four percent more murder to be
explored before press set more some I
don't know don't double content wait for
me what's new what's a challenges I like
challenges Oh
none of these work yet this game isn't
finished let's screw you then yay I'm
back baby hello what what is that what
is that well that's a fungi know that
but what is that Japanese weird
oh I'll goes these fundoshi me me love
me some comfy photo she's what is oh oh
it's even better than before here we go
what's different who's out here this is
a little different a little bit are you
any different what is that what is that
what is that hi the hell is that oh no
that is that's weird it's weird and
disturbing ooh a side door
all these wow it looks so nice
ah I like it I like it a lot oh this is
so pretty oh it's so damn pretty
that senpai senpai oh gosh oh gosh oh no
nothing shut up all of you look so nice
oh is that boobs McKenzie oh no wait
boobs McKenzie seems to be stuck boobs
McKenzie are you okay drown what I had
an option to drown her write that in
there you look great boobs McKenzie bad
you got your problem solved yeah yeah
what is wrong with you not in school
stop side humping oh don't you sight on
me okay [ __ ] are you are you oh you've
got a cute hairstyle oh you got
different colored eyes oh you think
you're so special you might
rival you my rival well murder you but
you're so nice I love you on the third
bed how do you feel far side hump you
yeah how do you like it
wait come back here I'm gonna make you
how do you like it miss I'm back here in
like Maine yeah so good no you look so
good he's smiling he's smiling at me oh
god oh whoa what the hell oh my god
I'm okay I have high reputation now why
hi who are you how's it going hi okay
never I know mommy
this isn't weird at all each oh I can
change my hair whoa alrighty then I like
this one it's cute that's Legend of
Korra that's who okay I'm super saying
ah word my senpai go one herb what I
don't know what the [ __ ] just happened
there okay Oh what is this
do you know the legend of the super
saiyan I saw resurrection F just
yesterday I went to the premiere that
was awesome hey come back here I'm
trying to talk to you get back here you
all fears his new regime right then I
can't actually see anything no idea
where you guys are
I hope this is my Stern a step bike
where's jump I overhear you my rival
come back here don't ignore the wrath of
the Super Saiyan where's my senpai
glorify with me forever
hey guys let's see them cool sorry
me oh oh now senpai will notice me
actually something went horribly wrong
with my boobs you know what if a super
saiyan just walked into your school and
her boobs just started growing and
shrinking at random I can't see sh and
pi I won't be embarrassed by him 10 by
10 PI all the way I'm sure I can be
trusted probably just don't worry about
a thing
don't worry about a thing maybe worry
about some things
haha oh not dead though just knocked out
correct
I believe so anyway I'm gonna take you
somewhere I don't know why I did this
what was the point of this I only have a
little blood on me hey what are you
looking at were you looking at Lumi
you're racist against Super Saiyans this
is serious cause for alarm
I'm a yandere look at my freakish nature
look at me hey I can speed up time
that'll be helpful oh my god bye bye
he's gotta be around here somewhere
yeah where shall I say bye oh there's my
somebody I don't know how is my I love
you I'll always love you
okay see you later after school I think
this was the correct room but I need to
do some other things I'm Eric come here
come here come here come here come here
okay so it said I have to close the door
this door go over here okay
now ah yeah see no spirt simple ah yeah
yeah
alrighty then and then I just have to
come back later a night but I can skip
the day by doing this I don't know I'm
yang this is really creepy to do but I
did it I did a new thing I don't even
know if that was a new thing but I did a
thing you're not the one I picked up
your blue hair wait why what was the
point of this what was the point of this
house is creepy I mean it was creepy
before but now it's just weird I mean it
was weird before but you know you know
no I really did wonder where all the
other students went I guess it's just me
and sent by now there's no one else in
school apparently one now it literally
it's just me it's just me and sent by
now now you'll have to love me
samurai-sama you weirded out all right I
understand
have a good day okay so that's yandere
simulator I know there's a few things
that I didn't get to but unfortunately
I'm too stupid to figure them out so I
might get to them in another episodes so
if there's anything else that you want
to see in this game let me know in the
comments below
also I crashed the game that's why I'm
back at the main menu I might have blown
up my entire recording but you'll know
that based on whether or not you see
this episode on YouTube right now so
thanks for watching it if it does exist
and thanks for trying if it didn't but
you didn't know that it didn't if you
didn't and there's no point for me
saying this at all wibbly-wobbly
timey-wimey crap
thanks again anyways and as always I
will see you in the next video
was it good snooze